[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka a friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and in the wake
of a lot of news coming up about the
upcoming MC project spider-man 3 has
been a couple of leaks that have made
their way to the web that I thought
deserved a closer inspection the main
one of these coming from Lord of the
leaks himself
Mikey Sutton who correctly reported on
spider-man joining the MCU way back in
Civil War as well as the Disney and Sony
negotiations being ongoing when many
said that the door was closed on the
30th of September the leaker posted a
status that said that the upcoming 2021
film spider-man 3 would be the darkest
of the Homecoming trilogy and that it
would feature the chameleon as a villain
as well as she-hulk who will be cameo in
the movie before her solo show on Disney
Plus I'll get into the post in just a
bit but this ties in with reports that
were posted a that the daredevil and
kingpin would be featuring in the film
and that Disney were planning on
resurrecting the Netflix shows through
Hulu I've already done a full video on
that so if you want to know more then
make sure you click the bar along the
top that links to the video anyway if
you still hear certain seemingly has a
lot of info on the upcoming movie and
whilst leaks like this should always be
taken with a grain of salt it does sound
like a pretty cool way to take a
character in the film the post itself
says the following
now that the dispute between Sony and
Disney over spider-man in the MCU has
been happily resolved the focus is on
filming spider-man 3 or more
specifically scripting the movie the
origin of the following scoop is not new
so whether changes will be made after
the new agreement remains to be seen
after all this wasn't sulphide back then
either there were discussions on having
the chameleon be the villain in the
third spider-man flick the plan it seems
is to have the movie be about a tale of
identities the hero whose identity is
revealed and the villain who steals
identities Marvel Studios sees this as
the darkest of the three films with a
slightly more grown-up Peter Parker who
has experienced so much already and is
about to go through a harrowing personal
journey at home most likely the
chameleon will be pretending to be
either Parker and/or spider-man causing
havoc whether the chameleon will be
affiliated with Dimitri and far from
home remains to be seen but I strongly
believe that this was simply
misdirection but will it just be the
chameleon watch Lord of the long box for
part two of this news live at 5 p.m. PST
today as the third Eclipse to involve
Parker's green skinned attorney against
another powerful foe these talks were
early so let's see what ends up staying
as the script is just being written how
will it be you'll fly in the ointment
Mikey so this sounds pretty cool and
whilst I was hoping that Kraven would be
the villain of the piece this aesthetic
actually works really well too I suppose
it's down to Sony how they want to bring
Kraven into the universe but as of now
we haven't had a date announced for the
film's solo film and thus it's a pretty
safe bet to assume that his outing will
probably be released after the
aforementioned spider-man 3 chameleons
could also be used to get Peters
identity back to being private as if he
is discovered in the film to be parading
around as the wall-crawler then the
Mysterio attacks that were blamed on
Parker could be shifted to him now again
this is a rumor and as Sutton says this
idea was brought up early in production
so it may not even make its way through
the scripting process so take this as
you will personally though I think this
sounds great and it would definitely
work in my opinion the Home Coming
trilogy is known for using villains that
haven't appeared in spider-man films
before and this at least on the surface
lines up with the aesthetic now
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this news and if you think it's true
or if you think it's just some Mysterio
fake news comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown that daredevil and
kingpin will appear in the MCU which
would be linked at the end I go over
everything you need to know about the
story so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more you want to
come chat to me about movies TV shows
games and comic books so make sure you
follow me on twitter at definition white
tea it's the best place to get in touch
with me and it's the perfect place to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully I see you over there after
this well so just wanna let you know
that we're currently giving away a free
copy of spider-man far from home on
blu-ray and all you have to do to be in
with the Chan
of winning is a like this video make
sure that you subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on the chameleon
news in the comment section below the
winner will be chosen at random on
October the 15th and the blu-ray will be
shipped out from the enter Birgit
surprise it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like it subscribe thanks again
to take the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you